ultra crémeux faible en sucre ou
islandais pour se soigner et cuisiner ou
se gâter il y a plus de 200 variétés de
yogourt dans les frigos de nos épiceries
une offre vaste pour répondre aux
besoins de plus en plus spécifiques de
la clientèle
[Musique]
ferme ou brassée fin de l'histoire
c'était très simple aujourd'hui on a des
variations de texture majeures on sort
le yogour de l'occasion simplement
collation et l'on va dans le dessert on
va dans l'ingrédient culinaire aussi
pour cuisiner puis aujourd'hui on va
consommer du goût beaucoup plus par
plaisir on a beaucoup moins peur des
matières grasses qu'à l'époque donc on
va aussi voir des yogourts qui
contiennent beaucoup plus de matière
grasse donc Théo qui vont être
indulgents voire même dessert il y a
quelques années jamais on aurait écrit
en gros sur un emballage 9% voire même
11% aujourd'hui on s'en vente parce
qu'il y a une expérience gustative
particulière qui est promise avec avec
ça on voit extra crémeux double crème
créma toutes les variations possibles
est-ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que tous les fabricants qui prennent
cette direction-là ou presque vont
réussir à augmenter l'anxiété du produit
en ajoutant davantage de crème plutôt
que de jouer avec des ateliers
texturants donc on ramène aussi le
yogourt dans sa forme plus naturelle
fraise vanille restent les plus grands
vendeurs dans la catégorie du yogourt
reste que plusieurs essais de tirer leur
épingle du jeu en nous apportant des
saveurs où on sort des sentiers battus
je pense entre autres produits
Versailles de Riviera avec la cardamome
et de la mangue il y en a un autre qui a
de la menthe dedans donc c'est pas des
saveurs auxquels on est habitué pour du
yoga on voit qu'il y a une nouvelle
offre ici un pot un peu chic en verre
des emballages beaucoup plus classique
si on veut dire on parle à qui avec ces
offres-là c'est une catégorie qui est
longtemps restée très très classique et
conservatrice pour arriver à sortir son
épingle du jeu et attirer notre
attention il faut se renouveler il faut
casser les repères comment il casse vous
voyez la différence de de l'offre ou de
la présentation entre mon produit
régulier de tous les jours ou l'autre
qu'on me présente qui est mon extra
crémeux un goût crémeux à faire rêver et
la couleur bleue et
l'approche visuelle sophistiqué plus
sophistiqué c'est ça
certains emballages que mouflent une
autre tendance celle de la raie
duflation une stratégie de réduction de
la taille ou du volume des produits pour
les vendre au même prix celui-ci est à
750 g c'est la quantité qu'on a eu
pendant très très longtemps ensuite je
descends c'est 50 630 625 lui qui est à
500 qui est clairement plus petit donc
là on n'a pas de surprise mais si vous
regardez ceci ils sont extrêmement
similaires en termes de formes et de
taille pourtant j'ai plus de 100 g de
différence entre le premier et le
dernier si l'offre explose les prix
aussi 14 % d'augmentation depuis deux
ans d'où l'importance de vérifier le
prix par portion de 100 g il y a plus de
260 produits différents se classant en
quatre grandes catégories d'abord les
fermes ou Balkans
la particularité d'un yogourt ferme
comme on le mot le dit c'est sa texture
mais pour arriver à cette texture là
c'est que la fermentation et le
refroidissement du produit se fait à
même le contenant dans lequel on
l'achète ensuite les deux plus
populaires
[Musique]
le yogourt brassé vous aurez compris que
le brasse donc la fermentation va se
faire encules on brasse le produit une
fois que le procédé est terminé et
ensuite ça va être emballé les yogourts
à boire la recette de base et la même on
ajoute un peu d'eau dedans pour les
rendre plus liquides ensuite on a les
yogourt Grecs donc la particularité du
yogourt grec c'est qu'une fois qu'il a
été fermenté il a été goûté c'est ce qui
fait que beaucoup plus épais en faisant
ça j'ai aussi réduire mon volume et donc
concentrer notamment les protéines dans
le produit il y a le fameux skieur à
l'origine en fait le ski révavantage
fait avec un yogourt sans gras donc
c'est ce qui fait que souvent les
skieurs sont encore plus faibles en
matière grasse
au rayon des nouvelles tendances on
remarque également l'ajout de protéines
de plantes et de céréales mais surtout
la réduction du sucre amorcé depuis les
deux dernières décennies puis on a une
diminution d'environ 30% du niveau de
sucre dans les dans les produits on a
aussi vu dans les tendances le yogourt
nature qui est en forte croissance les
gens vont cuisiner avec le yogourt donc
beaucoup plus de versatilité dans
l'usage du yoga
au bistrot Le Darnat le labené est mise
à l'honneur dans plusieurs plats pour
réaliser ce laitage le chef Othmane amer
et goût tout simplement un yogourt grec
du commerce comme étant on fait goûter
le yogourt pour en faire un avenir ça
prendrait contre deux à quatre heures
dépendamment de l'ongletité du yaourt
alors ce que ça donne ça donne une
texture beaucoup plus onctueuse on peut
l'utiliser dans un plat salé ou un plat
sucré moi je l'utilise beaucoup pour
substituer l'huile d'olive et le beurre
et la vérité c'est beaucoup plus santé
que de la crème ou du beurre c'est
beaucoup plus léger j'ai l'impression
que de plus en plus on voit le yogourt
sur les menus de plusieurs restaurants
au pays est-ce qu'une nouvelle mode
c'est sûr qu'il y a une mouvance où on
se dirige beaucoup plus vers
ne pas utiliser des viandes je prendrai
mon amené du jamais mélanger je mettrai
une quenelle puis l'étaler sur
l'assiette notre carte est à 80%
végétarienne donc le légume a toujours
besoin de quelque chose qui va le
réhausser le chef a préparé un steak
d'aubergine servit sur son yogourté et
un gâteau aux dattes et noix accompagné
de sa préparation maison longue sensée
aimer l'aubergine de façon qui est
présenté aujourd'hui rajouter le l'apnée
sur le sur le sur le gâteau voilà
je pourrais manger juste
une découverte pour moi merci à vous
merci